hallo mein name ist willkommen meine
liebe freunde ich hab euch auf instagram
gesagt dass ich mir mal wieder einige
fragen stellen sollte und ich würde
sagen damit fangen jetzt auch direkt an
luke hast du bist dumm und stinkt
ja danke für eure super fragen wieso
bist du so hässlich
macht echt mega spaß mit euch flirtet du
mit deinem kurz
zwischen see und land liegt
walsh
als wenn das wirklich der grund ist
heißt tomatenmark tomatenmark weil marc
tomatenmark
könnt ihr bitte auch wenn mit diesen
bescheuerten fragen wenn gift abläuft
wird es dann giftiger
dabei haben wir irgend eine vernünftige
frage hier bist du dumm ernst gemeint ja
gemeint warum bist du der lauteste
stinkt xtra und den besten merge
besitzen da und bester
hab keine ahnung was jetzt genau deine
frage war kannst du mir bitte zeigen wie
du diesen look immer schaffst ich habe
keine ahnung welchen look gemeint aber
ich habe gerade schlafen lande graue
jogginghose und socken aus dem lukas
gähwiler von de hast du brusthaare
ich hab
du auf meinem kopf fahrer eigentlich
eine meinung zu den protesten während
corona wegen der ansteckungsgefahr also
ich war ja vor einigen tagen selber auf
einer anti rassismus demo hier in köln
und wir beziehungsweise ich meine
freunde haben den sicherheitsabstand
selbstverständlich eingehalten
allerdings ist das natürlich nicht zu
gewährleisten wenn sich das 15.000 leute
treffen also auf der einen seite finde
ich extrem gut dass demonstrationen dass
leute protestieren das ist weiterhin
natürlich gang und gäbe ist und nicht
verboten ist
auf der anderen seite kollidiert ist
halt ein bisschen mit dem hygiene
konzept und den ganzen infektionsschutz
gesetzen aber das ist halt so schwierig
alles nebenher zu regeln längst durch
bestehe meinen führerschein ich habe
keine ahnung ob sie das schaffen
jetzt habe ich drückte auf jeden fall
beide daumen wie viele quadratmeter hat
ein haus in hamburg- ps macht nochmal
einen blog ich glaube du meinst lok
arnstadt block und ja sobald ich in
hamburg bin möchte ich auf jeden fall
wieder anfangen mehr zu blocken
einerseits den kompletten umzug
andererseits auch meine erste nacht in
der neuen wohnung generell dort ein paar
sachen allgemein ich in hamburg
da möchte ich ein bisschen flotten habe
ich auf jeden fall schon pläne
allerdings war die frage ja wie viel
quadratmeter mein haus hat
ich baue dort kein haus sondern eine
wohnung und die wohnung hat ein bisschen
mehr als 200 quadratmeter wird auf jeden
fall genug platz sein für meine dummheit
wie lange möchte die den podcast noch
durchziehen so lange wie es uns spaß
macht und das macht es gerade mehr denn
je und gestern kam vor allem auch eine
neue folge online also wenn ihr nicht
gehört habt spotify das lästig und du
würdest du fallschirmspringen machen
ich traue mich im schwimmbad noch nicht
mal vom fünfer zu springen
wie soll ich denn dann aus einem
flugzeug schaffen was sind deine
lieblings unterhosen und socken also was
unterhosen angeht habe ich keine
lieblings mag ich bestelle mir immer die
billigsten bases oder baut you und was
socken an geht halt die hier die gibt's
im koeln.de ist sandra oft betrunken
ich glaube
betrunken als nüchtern erlebt bist du
eigentlich religiös ja ich bin religiös
und zwar bin ich christlich katholisch
und glaube an gott allerdings überlege
ich die ganze zeit ob ich nicht aus der
kirche austrete dann hinter dem ganzen
konzept kirche stehe ich nicht aber ich
glaube an gott versteht ihr was ich
meine dann bekommst du mit sandra
endlich kinder
ich hoffe
welches auto fährst bin ich jetzt froh
wenn meine frage im video ist leider
nein leider gar nicht so nutella mit
butter oder ohne 140 oder zitrone
nutella auf jeden fall eben mehr mit
verstehen die leute nicht den teller
ohne butter essen und ice t 4 sich oder
zitrone safe für sich ich finde so
zitrone kann auch mal erfrischend sein
aber wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste
dann 40 und richtig wichtige fragen die
hier heute wieder beantwortet wie alt
bist du 24
und wie alt seid ihr schreibt mir und in
die kommentare wann bringst du deinen
eigenen t als merge raus eigentlich gar
nicht mal so schlechte idee ich liebe
tiere über alle hilfe kommt so themen
pizza geschmack schläfst du deiner
meinung nach fehlen also ich schlafe pro
nacht so meine sechs bis acht stunden
und damit legt sich mein leben
eigentlich auch ganz gut die sache ist
nur dass ich das nicht irgendwie von 0
bis 6 bis 8 uhr machte sondern halt
meistens irgendwie so von drei bis neun
oder 11 oder irgendwie so daran müsste
ich mal ein bisschen arbeiten
abi-schnitt wenn abiturschnitt war
irgendwas mit 2,3 27 85 90
irgendwas mit 2 vorn aber da fragt
mittlerweile eh keiner mehr nach meinung
zu gewitter im kopf hin und jan sind
zwei extrem liebe menschen ich mag die
beiden echt sehr sehr sehr sehr gern
allerdings ihr habt noch mal eine
rauschbrille da habt ihr euch haben wir
für ein video ausgeliehen und tim das
geld was sie aus dem stadion schulden
gebe ich dir auch demnächst irgendwann
wohnung oder eigenes haus meiner
jetzigen situation würde ich mich
hundertprozentig für die wohnung
entscheiden weil es einfach viel viel
viel viel viel viel weniger arbeit ist
als ein eigenes haus und vor allem ist
man viel sicherer für mich wenn ich mir
jetzt ein haus kaufen werde ich immer
angst wo irgendwie stalkern
irgendwelchen fanatischen fans keine
ahnung was ich meine wohnung entspannt
hat was viel viel viel weniger probleme
aber wenn ich irgendwann einen hund
haben sollte und ein bisschen älter bin
irgendwie so in zehn jahren und mit
frauen vielleicht kinderhandel oder
anzeichen aus irgendwo außerhalb und
geiler gartenpool basketballplatz
golfplatz helikopter landeplätze
hoffentlich kann mein hund dann auch
platz meinungen zur luciano
ich habe keine ahnung was das ist
falls wir den rapper meinst kann ich
nichts zu sagen höre ich die musik nicht
falls das irgendwie anders sein sollte
ich mich gerade blamiere ard es macht
ihr noch eine dick und doof community
folgejahr hundertprozentig weil das
sandra und mir auch mega viel spaß
gemacht hat einmal alle die nicht wissen
was - unterstrich unterstrich luca damit
meint ich habe ja einen podcast mit
sandra wie bereits gesagt haben gestern
eine neue folge aneinander und ich habe
vor einigen monaten uns in berlin
getroffen mit vier zufällig ausgewählten
podcaster und werden zusammen folge
aufgenommen soll ich die lustigen
zusammen bisschen bierchen getrunken und
wir wollen dass demnächst auf jeden fall
noch einmal in angriff nehmen mit
welchem prominenten mann würdest du am
ehesten ins bett steigen also ich bin ja
heterosexuell wenn ich allerdings
homosexuell wäre wäre es glaube ich
schon mendes
oder
special 08 15 einfache justin bieber
room to ich bereits in meinem letzten
instagram fragen beantworten video
gesagt kommt eventuell demnächst ihm
wann meine gute form einer wohnung in
köln allerdings will ich jetzt nicht
direkt meine wohnung in hamburg zeigen
ihr werdet die allerdings zwangsläufig
im hintergrund sehen wenn ich videos
macht er wenn ich blogge et cetera aber
ich will jetzt nicht so wie baby eine
halbe stunde euch durch mein ganzes ding
irgendwie durchführen weil halt
privatsphäre wo siehst du dich in zehn
jahren ich glaube das habe ich vor
einigen fragen ja gerade schon so ein
bisschen angedeutet und zwar sehe ich
mich so in zehn jahren mit einem haus in
mit einem großen garten mit einer frau
mit kindern und einem hund irgendwo
leben ein richtiges standard leben will
ich haben ich sehe mich jetzt nicht
irgendwie in zehn jahren der weltreise
machen und keine ahnung wie was wo
pipapo sondern halt einfach ganz normal
ich hatte bisher ein ganz normales leben
und so kann es auch gern weitergeben
willst du dir einen hund holen wenn ja
welchen bei einigen monaten habe ich mir
noch die ganze zeit gesagt ja auch luca
sobald du in hamburg bist musst du dir
definitiv einen hund holen weil hier in
köln wurde ich gerade was zwei
stockwerke in hamburg wird nur noch ein
stockwerk sein und das ist für hunde ja
auch blöd denn die treppen laufen müssen
ich habe in hamburg einen fahrstuhl muss
der hund nicht das treppenhaus hoch
laufen weil hier in köln ich hatte
keinen fahrstuhl also ganz viele punkte
einfach die pro hund in hamburg sprechen
können bzw einfach sprechen die sache
ist allerdings dass ich glaube ich den
hund gerade noch immer nicht so viel
liebe und sei dagegen bringen kann wie
es gern machen wollen würde weil jetzt
gerade diese zeit pro tag in die acht
bis neun stunden vom pc macht videos und
aber ja irgendwann hundertprozentig und
ich will dass meine kinder mit einem und
aufwachsen was ist dein lieblingslied
aktuell hauseingang von pagani letzte
woche beim instagram fragen beantworten
was er noch airwaves aber jetzt gerade
sehr viel hauseingang tatsächlich
lieblingsserie also mit herrn scheuch
gerade die neue staffel starten reasons
why ecke tote mädchen lügen nicht
allerdings gibt es ja mal eine generelle
lieblingsserie und ich glaube das ist
stromberg bzw
wie office weil das einfach so ein
stumpfer dummer humor ist da habe ich
mir auch ganz viel um eine redeweise ist
auch von da und stromberg was ist mit
kollegen da schild ukulele was soll mit
der sein wenn du eine sache an youtube
ändern könnte es was wäre das also da
ich ja selber youtuber binnen und die
plattform nicht nur zum konsum nutzen
sondern wirklich auch zum selber
hochladen und haltet es bei einer
arbeitsplattform mehr oder weniger ist
habe ich da vielleicht eine andere
ansicht als beispielsweise ihr dient
also als leute die ihr sich einfach nur
videos anschauen würde ich sagen die
werbe freundlichkeit weil wenn ich jetzt
sage loch werde ich das nicht geliebt
hätte gerade werden hier einfach keine
anzeichen auf ein video und 45 stunden
die den senior einfließen werden einfach
mit null euro beglichen worden
also diese komplette werbe
freundlichkeit sache die würde ich ein
bisschen lockerer machen bis zu den
planungen die irgendwann mal ein anderes
auto zu holen also momentan habe ich ja
noch meinen ferrari hier aber
tatsächlich ja ich bekomme tatsächlich
nächste woche neues auto aber vom tisch
rota dazu auch noch mal ein video auf
meinem 2 kanal machen indem ich euch das
kurz vorstellen
er will nächste woche oder danach die
woche was ist dein lieblingsgericht ich
es eigentlich jeden tag irgendetwas mit
reis aber sonst würde ich sagen ihnen
wie trüffel nudeln mit knoblauch und
scampi so john ding ist das nämlich wer
sollte deiner meinung nach in der
zweiten liga aufsteigen da ich ja selber
auch wieder fällt kommt natürlich
hundertprozentig der dsc ich glaube die
machen es auch safe als erster auf den
zweiten platz sehe ich aktuell den vfb
stuttgart den gar nichts auch weil mit
den fans gehören die einfach in die
zweite liga und auf den dritten platz
sehe ich den hsv
und dann hoffe ich dass es ein richtig
geiles relegationsspiel gibt zwischen
hamburg und bremen
dass das wäre auf jeden fall richtig
krass hast du noch vor einen eigenen
song raus zu bringen also singen werde
ich auf gar keinen fall niemals ergeben
ich hier meine hand drauf
es gibt ja ganz viele youtuber die sich
denken über eine reichweite jetzt fange
ich an zu singen macht damit noch gelten
kann ich nicht weiß ich auch dass ich
kann weil ich mal atemlos durch die
nacht singen
atemlos durch die nacht
neuer tag erwacht um allerdings auf die
frage zurückzukommen ich könnte mir das
schon vorstellen eigene songs zu bringen
allerdings kein song wo ich selbst singe
sondern vielleicht eher im hintergrund
bin also ist nicht im hintergrund stehen
mit einer trommel oder so sondern als
produzent agieren
irgendwie gebiet mache mir die ganze
konzeption überlege das ganze ding
produziere et cetera pp allerdings will
ich an der stelle das sollte ich will
jetzt aber entweder lieben freunde wenn
ihr in der nächsten fragestunde mit luca
eine frage stellen wollten auf instagram
da frage ich euch nämlich immer noch den
fragen allerdings befinden uns jetzt
auch schon im auto meiner lieben freund
und zwanziger oben ein smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf könnt ihr
ein kanal kostenlos abonnieren verpasst
keine videos mehr das mega entspannt
wenn ich ein abonnent seit der krieg
doch die glocke auch cool da kriegt ihr
benachrichtigen wenn ich so ein neues
video hochladen und hier ist ein anderes
video verlegt mensch war letzte woche
die frage nicht beantwortet habe also
klingt das